On Tuesday, April 4th, 2023
Donald Trump entered
a Manhattan courtroom
and pled not guilty
to 34 crimes.
It's one step in a long process
that will likely lead
to the first criminal trial
of a former US president.
Trump acted in
unprecedented ways
and now there is an unprecedented
response to how he acted.
Trump lost the 2020 election and
left office in January of 2021...
and since then, lawyers have been
gathering evidence
in 4 separate criminal investigations.
They are trying to figure out
if Trump broke the law...
and if he did, what to do about it.
To understand these
4 different cases
you need to know a little bit
about how criminal investigations
in the US work.
In the first phase, investigators
gather evidence.
They might interview witnesses,
review surveillance footage
comb over financial records or
review texts and emails.
They show that evidence to
a randomly selected
group of citizens called
a grand jury.
The grand jury's job
isn't to decide
if anyone is innocent
or guilty.
They just listen to the evidence
and basically decide
if it makes sense.
If 12 of them think it does,
they'll issue an indictment.
Only then can the prosecutor
file charges.
The accused can plead guilty,
in which case
the whole thing goes
straight to sentencing.
If they plead not guilty
then the case goes to trial
and a jury hears the evidence
and has to come to a unanimous decision
one way or the other.
Obviously, a simplification
and there's a ton of variations
in different states and jurisdictions,
but that's the gist.
So where do things stand with those
for Trump investigations?
Let's start with the hush money.
The state of New York has
officially charged Trump
with falsifying business records
in the first degree.
In its statement of facts, the prosecutors
write that
he repeatedly and fraudulently falsified
New York business records to
conceal criminal conduct
that hid damaging information
from the voting public
during the 2016 presidential election.
This bank statement from Trump's former
lawyer, Michael Cohen
shows that he withdrew funds
in October of 2016.
He then used that money to pay
an adult film actress
to stay quiet about an affair
that she said
she'd had with Donald Trump
a few years earlier.
A year later, after Trump had won
the presidency
he wrote several checks
to reimburse Cohen.
In his accounting records
Trump designated these as
payments for legal services
which isn't exactly accurate.
This is some of the evidence
that led to Trump's
recent indictment and
his not guilty plea.
In order to convict Trump
of a felony
the district attorney,
Alvin Bragg
he has to prove not just that
he falsified these records
in order to cover up
the payments
but he has to prove
that he did so
in order to advance or cover up
some other crime.
But I think that these
particular allegations
against Trump are pretty
far afield of
the really serious allegations
that justify going after
a former president.
You know, the allegation that
he tried to steal an election.
“In Georgia, the votes are
still being counted.”
“CNN has just projected President-elect
Biden the winner in Georgia.”
“I believe that the numbers
that we have presented today
are correct.”
There is a phone call between
Donald Trump
and Brad Raffensperger, the Secretary
of State of Georgia.
The top elections official in Georgia.
If they magically came up
with 11,780 Trump votes
that didn't actually exist
that would have been enough to
steal the election in Georgia.
A special grand jury in Georgia
has heard the evidence
and recommended multiple indictments.
But we don't know yet if
District Attorney Fani Willis
is going to take things further.
The Georgia team isn't the only one
trying to figure out if
Trump's behavior after the election
broke any laws.
Federal special counsel
Jack Smith’s team
is looking into similar questions.
There's been a lot of attention
on this question of
fake electors.
The state's electors
cast their votes
for whoever won the most votes
in their state.
If Biden wins the state,
then Biden's electors
win the state and he gets
that many electoral votes.
The Trump team wins
key swing states.
They tried to assemble slates
of alternative electors
even though Biden won the state.
Security wouldn't let them in.
So they signed the document
in the basement of the state's
Republican headquarters.
Then sent it off to DC.
Trump's team led similar efforts in
six other states where Biden won.
A grand jury in DC has been
hearing evidence
in this case for months but
they haven't voted yet.
But we appear to be in
the closing stages of this.
The same special prosecutor
is also looking into
a fourth case against Trump.
“Unprecedented FBI search at the home of...”
[overlapping] “Trump's Mar-a-Lago property...”
“...has been raided by the FBI.”
This inventory list from the raid
shows that they found
dozens of documents labeled classified,
confidential, and top secret.
There's a Washington Post report
last year that some of this
involved nuclear documents.
There has been some reporting
that some of these
related to intelligence that
could have exposed
certain US informants or sources...
and that basically the
intelligence community
did consider this really
important stuff
that should not have been hanging out
at Mar-a-Lago.
Right now, a grand jury in DC is
still hearing all this evidence.
As president, Donald Trump didn't just
say outrageous things.
He acted in ways that no president
ever had before.
Now that he's no longer in office
it's time to figure out if any
of that unprecedented behavior
was also illegal.
And if it was
what to do about it.